good morning john i'm actually really
worried right now
and that's not a surprise i have a
specific worry though that i'd like to
talk about in this video
uh regarding the higher education system
in the u.s
colleges and universities they're just
extremely important right
vital but here are three true things
first schools have been raising prices
faster than inflation for over 40 years
now if it had over the course of my
lifetime
increased with inflation the cost of
four years of school after financial aid
would be about 40
000 now that's a lot and it's an average
so there would be schools that would be
way above that in schools that would be
below that instead it is now over 90
000 and so almost definitionally
every year college gets less worth it
thing number two
it's going to be less valuable if it's
an all online experience
and yet schools are not like lowering
prices and finally there is an
increasingly large number of people in
this country who
actually think that college is bad for
america in fact in 2016 a year in which
some other shifts occurred in america
the percentage of republicans who
believe that college
has a negative effect on the country
went from 37
to 58 and that isn't just an opinion the
trump administration is doing things
to hurt universities making it harder
for international students to stay in
the country having the treasury
department investigate whether or not
non-profit universities should have
their tax-exempt status revoked and
these are big deals
23 percent of the money that comes into
the u.s higher education system comes
from international students who are
often the only ones
who pay full price so international
students very clearly subsidize the
education of americans so while at first
this looks like another anti-immigrant
thing it's actually both an
anti-immigrant thing
and an anti-education thing now it's
really hard and complicated
to get to the roots of where this
antagonism between some people in
america
and the higher education system comes
from it's hard it's historical it's
convoluted this isn't simple but
part of it and definitely not the whole
thing because the whole thing is much
more sinister
is that colleges are elitist they want
to be
elite institutions for elite students
that's that's how they'd like to pitch
themselves and that's how we found
ourselves in a world where the number
one metric for how good a school is
is how many students it rejects this is
under examined and pretty gross and it's
to the point where schools will actually
encourage students who they know they
are going to reject to apply
in order to keep their acceptance rates
low so we cannot say that to some extent
this system hasn't contributed to this
problem so again higher education is the
victim of three things right now
decades of this hubris where they think
they can just
keep raising prices to compete with each
other a pandemic that's going to
decrease the value of education and
an administration that doesn't care we
have to fix
all of those problems and they are all
hard some of them
for good reasons some of them i am
shocked by how difficult they are but
here's the reason i have hope because if
this is survivable and i think that it
is
we will survive it by coming to terms
with the fact that higher education has
created a tremendous amount of good
while also allowing their budgets to get
way out of control in order to compete
with each other like businesses fighting
for customers
instead of schools educating students
the cost of higher education
needs to not just stop going up it needs
to start coming down this is our chance
to figure out how to do that and it's
something we think about
every day at complexly where our goal is
to create free educational materials
that make teaching cheaper and easier
but also with bigger ideas like our
partnership with arizona state
university but the thing to know here is
that right now
we are at the very beginning of a change
in how higher education
works a change that needs to be done
thoughtfully and carefully despite the
fact
that we have no choice but for it to
happen quite quickly and that's gonna be
hard
and that is why i'm worried and i just
wanted to articulate that
john i'll see you on tuesday